(upbeat music)
(tapping)
- Dance is something that comes
in every last one of us, from birth.
What we do is take that and give them
an opportunity to personalize it.
And then it empowers us
to dance at this level.
(upbeat music)
(tapping)
My name is Melba Mitchell-Ayco,
and I'm the founder of
Northwest Tap Connection.
Our mission is to close the gap
for underserved communities,
with an emphasis on children of color.
And really just open that
door for young people
who would not be able
to have accessibility
to the arts because of cost,
to have those opportunities
that are enriching.
When I started Northwest Tap, I was working
for the Seattle Police Department.
And my goal was that
children that I got to see
on a weekly basis, I would
never see across my desk.
This walkin' peace is very
much about our culture.
And you need to dance it that way.
Tap dancing is the foundation
of our organization.
I strive to make sure
that children understand
that it is a dance form that
comes out of black culture.
- Up the beat and up on the end.
Let me see that.
- [Melba] It comes out of protest.
And we have to appreciate it,
embrace it and protect
it as we pass it down.
(tapping)
- Northwest Tap is a race and
social justice oriented studio,
and being an African
American male, I don't think,
had I danced at another studio,
that I would have been surrounded
by so many fellow African Americans.
And I feel like that has given me
the confidence to feel
comfortable in my skin.
In normal everyday life,
I don't really like talking very much.
But when it comes to dancing,
I'm able to just communicate
in a way that touches people
rather than what they're just hearing.
(speaking faintly)
- Why?
- My feelings
as I watch young people dance...
There is this sense of pride
for the work that they do.
But then at the same time,
there's this sense of
fear and trouble, for me.
How much longer will we
continue with this struggle?
Dance is such an empowering tool.
We are a community of
many colors, many genders,
identifications, but we are one.
Through these children that dance,
we're creating a new tomorrow.
(upbeat music)
(tapping)
(electronic music)